so uh i am curious for all three of you
which of your friends and family were
the most excited uh when you told them
that you were going to be joining the
mcu
my brothers
um
because they're just huge marvel fans
you know they're they're guys they watch
all those movies they think they're the
coolest things in the world
and they never thought when i was
auditioning they were like there's no
way you'll get that there's just no way
you'll never be a superhero um but they
they freaked out
yeah my mine was um uh
two people one friend
called luke who's a huge mcu fan he was
very excited and my agent
was very excited as well
because he's an mcu fan not just because
of the
sure it's a two-fold thing though yeah i
mean it's a little bit he's just happy
on every level yeah
yeah my whole family yeah loved it
um do you guys think that the eternals
could have beaten thanos um on their own
without any involvement or would he have
won
i think we definitely i feel like yeah i
feel like we could have i feel like
maybe some smarter decisions could have
been made
do you mean thanos thanos on his own
yeah well yeah i guess you could you
know does he have the people with him is
he on his own let's say on his own
yeah without without a question
um i i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of movies um
for all three of you what do you guys
think would surprise fans to learn about
the actual making of eternals
it felt a lot like a
like a this is maybe really off like
weird but it felt like a drama when we
were filming it to me
it felt i don't know why but it felt
very emotional and
dramatic and then when you watch the
movie there's a lot of comedy there is a
lot of drama too but it's i don't know
for some reason when i was shooting it
it really felt like an indie film i
guess that might have been from chloe
being a part of it but
yeah the surprising it's surprisingly
from you know i was in a limited amount
of it but
from what i hear a lot of it was on
location
more so than than other marvel movies
which is kind of a surprising thing
about it it was very location based yeah
yeah that's that's the one
i was gonna say
physical location
uh one of the things that's so striking
and i'm sure you've talked about this
with other people but the cinematography
in this movie is unlike any other mcu
film before it and um it's just
beautiful to look at can you sort of
talk about um your reaction when you
realize what chloe was going for and
just you know working within that
environment because it's just so
beautiful to look
at yeah i thought i think we all you
know speak for all of us maybe that we
knew we were in the hands of a of an
incredible director
and even before nomad land had come out
and she won the the academy award like
we you know we knew of her previous work
and knew how beautifully she could shoot
things and photograph things
and
um that was a big reason i i wanted to
come in on this movie
meeting chloe knowing of her work and
knowing that it would look
beautiful
as well as as well as being spectacular
i mean i didn't really know what to
expect coming into it i was very pleased
to hear that we weren't always shooting
on sound stages and we're traveling a
lot and going to some beautiful places
and i think that brings
a lot to the movie that the audience
will find really special
when going to the theaters and seeing it
you know getting an iced tea and some
popcorn and watching the movie
yeah oh i was uh
already a big fan of chloe after
watching uh
the writer
so uh
i used to leave a place like that yeah
in like montana texas and i was
impressed uh after watching the movie
and
i became a big fan and then i that's why
uh i just
trusted her 100
when i was shooting so i was just
focused on my job
uh on that note i gotta stop i'm just
gonna say i really hope the film is a
huge hit and thank you so much for
giving me your time thank you